welcome to Gareth learn things I'm Guy
Fieri all right today we are at accuvita
in Highland Park and we're going to
learn about acupuncture now that's where
someone puts a ton of needles in you to
sort of relieve pressure in your I don't
really know but we're gonna learn it
that's what we're here for so let's
dance
[Music]
now you're an acupuncturist you do many
types of things or you focus on
acupuncture
um I focus on acupuncture but I
incorporate a lot of other holistic
treatments facial acupuncture
microneedling so facial acupuncture
because I'm noticing right now you have
needles in your face right now
do I
yeah yeah if you look closely there's
like 10 of them oh my gosh yeah they've
been you just kind of forget at this
point now how old is acupuncture it's
got to be real what is it thousands of
years thousands of years do we have any
idea where it started
um its Origins are in China do we know
who the first person was that had to be
a real leap of faith for someone just
being like hey Greg I'm gonna put a
bunch of needles in your face and he's
like ah and then what about the first
time when you're giving someone
acupuncture you don't tell them you
don't go like hey this is my first time
oh my God right you're like no it's a
very relaxing calming experience and I
know you gotta play the role you have
that that narrative in your head and you
just fake it till you make it and then
so the first time you do it are you
nervous when you're popping the needles
in someone yeah absolutely the first
person I need my dad that's pretty cool
a little easier that's way better that
was way better right because he's gonna
be like that's great yeah you're really
doing great honey yeah what a good
career move do people ever freak out
like have you ever had someone like
you've put a bunch of needles in them
and then they start kind of freaking out
and they want them out or something like
that yeah a couple of times but you
can't quickly you know you can't like be
like there you go like you've got a one
by one I'm right most people that freak
out they let me know in advance that
they're afraid of needles I'm probably
gonna freak out today Dr Zelena yeah
where is the weirdest place you've
acupunctured someone we'll do it for you
well I'd love to have an answer to the
question it's called Ren one that's the
name of the point Ren one yeah okay now
for those of us who aren't who gave our
phones to someone else where is the ren
one located I can show you on the
diagram what is the sensation like when
you get a needle in you what is it what
is it is it describable can you put it
magical magical it feels magic starts to
happen in your body magic starts to
happen the body starts to heal it you
know in in the 1400s you'd have been
hanged are you a little are you excited
to put needles in yeah yeah you seem a
little too amped up honestly I feel like
you're back in your like 20 party days
and like you know what I mean you're
like all right let's paint on this guy
yeah let's do it all right all right
well
[Music]
so these are all the places where you
could put a needle in a man yep so the
main points are
on meridians which are these invisible
channels of energy and we have over 365
main points one for each day one for
each day is that is it correlated to
that or that's just random that it's
365. I don't know I don't think
anything's random in life
there's different channels foreign
yep we rarely do those yeah with so many
options for points we usually don't have
to choose the points that are you know
in undesirable locations okay yeah right
but someone would have to specifically
be in and like hit the tongue and you'd
be like okay those are used like in
resuscitation situations more emergency
so if someone passed out you would like
needle their tongue traditionally really
you could
you have to remember this practice has
I've never been in a room where
someone's passed out and someone's been
like does anyone here no acupuncture
this was the medicine thousands of years
ago where there were no hospitals there
were so there was just like this guy
passing on they just [__] need yeah
okay all right where's the ren one I'm
I'm starting to think okay so that
you're you we're not doing Ren one I
mean that is aggressive that is the
gooch
you're not that's tincture puncture
you're right I've never actually needled
that point you've never done there no I
remember being in an intern in clinic
and there was a patient that was willing
to allow us to needle run one for
educational purposes I think this person
was a little like I'll let you guys do
it if you want to I would hate it as
he's just sitting like um and they were
like you want to come see no thanks I'm
good people so you were around people
who got the taint needle yeah
I'll tell you red one is a misleading
term that's really putting a shine on
some [__] honestly I think you really
want to know what Ren one's like
um
there is something are you ready for a
renovation now that we're talking about
it my last name is Reynolds
oh my God maybe I'm the chosen one The
Chosen Ren one
[Music]
I would like to suggest that we work a
little bit on your face just to enhance
your beautiful skin and facial features
because you're on camera all the time
thank you all the time and we'll do when
aren't I shooting we'll do an overall
Chi balancing on the body just to
increase the energy a little bit
regulate it a little bit sure um do you
have a lot of stress in your life yeah
okay right now someone's about to put
needles on me
so we'll do some ear acupuncture for
that oh my God acupuncture you want to
do it and there's just one needle that
goes in the red normally or do you do a
bunch in the render how many would you
like I'm looking like really packing him
really let's get nuts what not nuts
um okay all right you do whatever I'm
ready I'm yours do it okay okay
wow okay so you definitely feel the
needle going in your face is it hurting
it doesn't hurt but I mean that one kind
of hurt actually now that we're talking
about what hurts and what doesn't
now are these all new needles or are you
do you clean the needles no I just used
them okay that's cool that's fine I love
the sharing needles when is that ever
been they are all sterile single use but
you're like I mean there's we already
have like 15 needles in my face you're a
typical dude oh
don't don't say that to me Dr Selena
I am so much more than your typical dude
I just had needles typical dude's
reaction you really do feel
that one was a dream come true how if
you had to guesstimate how many needles
you're gonna put in me today
like roughly 55.
actually it's probably pretty accurate
you so you were saying that as like an
absurdity and then you're like actually
that's what I'm doing so that's cool
that you're like I'll tell him a joke oh
what's happening
water at the end of it it'll shoot out
of all the little holes we can try and
see I'd love to try and see
are there times where your mind's
drifting and you're just jabbing needles
and someone and just going like ah hello
that's like being at Claire's
feel like a 15 year old girl at Claire's
right now my mom's gonna be so pissed
when she finds out that I did this
uh
you don't there's oh you still gonna
leave me here yep well you have to stay
you can't you is that what you do do you
normally leave people of course what if
and then do you ever hear anyone
shouting like
well I give them this handy dandy little
pager so they can call me oh so it's
like a Joe's Crab Shack waiting for a
table
[Music]
oh hello I wanted to talk to you about
something I think you left a few of the
needles when you left in me yeah
oh
Dr Zelena yeah after this can I put one
of myself as a treat for being so good
while I sleep you're supposed to be
sleeping I'm gonna sleep now and then
but as a treat afterwards can I put one
in myself maybe thank you okay thank you
all right I mean to distract you that's
cool
Dr Selena
I'm cooked
you ready yeah I think so oh I have seen
it
okay
once a month I bleed from my rent is
that normal
[Music]
don't answer
and take the needles out of my face you
want to do the honors I mean I can it's
it's gonna kind of be like guessing a
little bit do you wanna look in the
mirror
uh I know I like this yeah okay
oh
can I pretend like I'm Indiana Jones and
I just got hit with a bunch of them you
sure could uh Dr Zelena
they really came at me all right oh my
God oh my God I can't find oh that one
hurts still oh
Burns that's Elena ah
a good look ah sorry I didn't realize
okay so what did we learn today well
today I learned that needles don't hurt
when they go into your face they do hurt
when they go into your ear and that I
don't know how they feel when they go
into your Ren because I wouldn't allow
it
foreign
[Music]